the
oma festival celebrates the life of a
second century rabbi
and it is one of the holiest festivals
in the jewish calendar
last year's events were curtailed
because of covert this year
10 000 pilgrims were allowed to attend
but more than a hundred thousand turned
up
it was the largest legal public
gathering in israel since the pandemic
and it ended in tragedy
[Music]
we don't know exactly what caused the
stampede but thousands were crushed into
narrow passageways
and it quickly became chaotic some of
the men tried to pull down
corrugated walls to escape they've been
put up
to keep people apart because of covert
children some of them only two or three
years old became separated from their
parents
some were trampled on and died despite
paramedics attempts to resuscitate them
we were standing and waiting for our
friends we were gonna
go inside for the dancing and stuff and
uh
all of a sudden we saw paramedics from
madame whatever
running by uh like mid cpr
on uh on kids uh and then one after the
other started coming on ambulances
uh then we understood like something's
going on here
mobile phone reception went down as
people frantically tried to find loved
ones
and the israeli military sent
helicopters to evacuate the worst
injured a call for blood donations has
gone out across israel today
we reached the place we realized it is a
totally different incident
we are in a mass casualty incident i see
here tens of people lying on the floor
i see here tens of injured walking and
bleeding
israel's prime minister benjamin
netanyahu resisted calls to put coveted
restrictions on this year's festival
he visited the site in person on friday
morning
[Music]
this is the worst civilian disaster in
modern israeli history
condolences have been sent from world
governments there are some jewish
pilgrims who want to continue the
festival today
but so far the police are preventing
them from doing so
alas the bunker sky news